هل يعود قذافي آخر على رأس هرم السلطة الليبية؟
سيف الإسلام القذافي يعلن ترشحه للرئاسة؟
هل حان لليبيين أن يستبشروا ويحتفلوا؟
هل حانت نهاية فوضى دامت لأكثر من عقد من الزمن؟
أو لا يحق لليبيين أن يقرروا مصيرهم؟
واختيار من يقود بلادهم؟
وهل ستترك الدول الغربية والدول -التي تعتبر نفسها
وصية على دولة ذات سيادة
- قبضتها عن بلاد العقيد؟ هل يعود ابن العقيد ليواصل مسيرة والده
التي دامت لأكثر من ٤٠ عاما؟....
كل هذه الأسئلة وغيرها يتساءل بها الشعب الليبي،
الذي تعتريه الحسرة والندامة على قائدهم الراحل
العقيد معمر القذافي،
فقد غرقت ليبيا في الفوضى بعد أحداث 2011،
وتسعى حالياً إلى تجاوز هذا الفصل
بعد حوار سياسي أُطلق في تشرين الثاني/ نوفمبر 2020
بين الأطراف الليبية في سويسرا برعاية الأمم المتحدة،
وأدى الى وقف لإطلاق النار وتشكيل حكومة انتقالية
يفترض أن تشرف على الانتخابات الرئاسية
في 24 كانون الأول/ ديسمبر المقبل.
هل ترك العقيد القذافي الخلاص للشعب الليبي
عن طريق نجله؟
في العام ٢٠١١ أسرت مجموعة مسلحة سيف الإسلام القذافي،
لكن المجموعة رفضت تسليمه للسلطات الرسمية،
وفي العام ٢٠١٥ حكم على سيف الإسلام بالإعدام،
صرحت المجموعة بعدها بأنها قد أطلقت سراحه،..
فلماذا اختفى سيف الإسلام كل هذه المدة؟
كان آخر ظهور لسيف الإسلام
في مقابلة متلفزة خاصة أجرتها معه "قناة العاصمة" الليبية
عام 2013.
أما اليوم فقد تناقلت وسائل التواصل صورا له وقد اشتعلت لحيته شيبا،
أكان ذلك بسبب حزنه وألمه على حال بلاده
التي جعلها والده تقف ضد أقوى الدول في العالم!
أما اليوم فهي لا تستطيع الوقوف أساسا!
فالبلاد صارت لمن هب ودب يتقاسمون خيراتها
ويقتلون أبناءها،
ويعملون كمرتزقة للدول الخارجية....
.. مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي  أظهرت صورا ومقاطع مصورة
لسيف الإسلام، وهو داخل فرع مفوضية الانتخابات في سبها،
ويرتدي عباءة وعمامة .. فهل حان الوقت يا ابن العقيد!!!....
سيف الإسلام عاد إلى الواجهة بعد ١٠ أعوام من مقتل أبيه العقيد،،،،
ويحاول التذكير بأنه متهم بجرائم ضد الإنسانية
كما يدعون للحيلولة دون وصوله لكرسي الرئاسة،
بينما أعلن سيف الإسلام أنه أصبح الآن "رجلا حرا" ويخطط لعودة سياسية.
وتشعر الجماهير الليبية بالحنين إلى الماضي،
وإلى حالة الاستقرار والمجد في عهد والد سيف الإسلام،
وهو ما يجعل منه أبرز المرشحين للانتخابات القادمة،
في المقابل يتصدر المواجهة ملف خليفة حفتر المدعوم خارجيا -
والذي سبق وخان العقيد ليصل للحكم-
فهل ينتقم سيف الإسلام لوالده ممن أوغل في الخيانة والعمالة؟ ..
في ملف الانتخابات أيضا يقف رئيس الوزراء عبدالحميد الدبيبة،
كما سيكون هناك مرشحون آخرون مثل رئيس البرلمان عقيلة صالح
و وزير الداخلية السابق فتحي باشاغا،
ورئيس تكتل إحياء ليبيا عارف النايض،،،
كل هؤلاء المرشحين كانت ستقوى شوكتهم في الانتخابات
لولا أن ترشح سيف الإسلام القذافي ما رجح شوكته عليهم،
لكن هل تكفي الأموال الخارجية مجددا
لترجيح كفة حفتر وإغواء شعب لن يلدغ من جحر مرتين!!!
بعد ظهوره بعباءة والده بين بعض أنصاره منهم المحامي خالد الزايدي،
عاد بريق الأمل لليبيين في من يخرجهم من هذه الفوضى العارمة
التي أحالت البلاد إلى الخراب تماما،
فهل يعيد سيف الإسلام أمجاد أبيه ويقود دفة البلاد إلى بر الأمان؟ ...
لكن قبل ذلك على الليبيين أن يحددوا مصيرهم ويختاروا قائدهم،
فيا ترى من سيكون هذا القائد؟
....